great pictures just stop tonight
they paint they capture something that
did not continue it just wasn't then
we're looking through these pictures
we're clicking through yeah I've seen
that before I've seen that before
then this is froggen the crystals like
we've never seen that before how could
you have seen that before it's the
composition - it's the inclusion of
those three lights on the right the red
heart of the frog see right and then
that cord going down like each of those
elements is necessary to make that
composition as beautiful as it is that's
true you could give me a page to read on
this never never believe why how this
photographer happened to have his camera
at this moment that is mad
and who would ever know that bird
activity would involve that thing open
that one down by its tongue
photographers can spend their life
trying to photograph flickers and
woodpeckers never come across that
moment of one bird catching the other
birds by the top that's just that's like
it's one in a bazillion the soldier is
breakdancing and all his friends are
gathered around and if you if you look
close and look into their expression
good everyone's like oh no that is sick
I mean they got these huge smiles in
their their eyes are closed because
they're smiling somebody and this is
this great moment of soldiers Eddie's we
do get a lot of black and white and this
is perfect for this one because the
emphasis is on the emotion between these
two people the defiance of the child of
course is just captured it's like
crosses all languages all ages I mean
who hasn't been that kid you know now
I'm not gonna do that
listen here looking at these caribou
deter totally freaked out this is giant
truck roaring across the landscape in
the snow in the winter why was this
photographer out there busy of a
telephone
and you know he's about to get trampled
by these caribou who were about to get
trampled by this truck and why any of
the elements of the scene including the
photographer were in this place epic I
just I will never know and I'll continue
to look at that picture
anyway I've seen it so many times but I
can it's just it's perfect more than the
hair is blowing the lips are perfectly
beautiful anyone would love to look at
those lips and it's perfect if we don't
need to see your eyes it's not about the
eyes it's about the lips and the
crayfish this picture inspires wonder at
the empathy of these animals for one of
their own but at the same time mooning
crushes you emotionally you can see it's
just a moment his foot is just moving
past they're just moving through and the
person on the right holding gently
holding the face as if she must have
known and he swaddle you know Wilbur oh
yeah it's the combination of elements
that make you stay inside the frame you
just get whirling around in the frame
the entire activities right smack in
that frame
god what a composition mr. perfect light
perfect action the right feet action and
it all comes down that tongue says hope
it just comes down that one little thing
what were they doing with their camera
and the foreplay in there and I'll tell
you what they were doing I think this
isn't Hawaii and they're sitting around
like having a mai tai eating their love
and rank high and put down the fork and
staring off at the water Oh wasn't that
nice yeah look does it get going my pie
dance that's how it happens